this year only murders in the building
is focusing on the world of theater
where you have to perform live
why are you acting like I don't
understand that you have to make a
connection with the audience give
everything you have every performance
yeah I've literally toured the entire
world being on stage in the spotlight
it's just
it's hard to describe
[Music]
oh good you're back welcome to one
killer question the only murders in the
building after show I'm your host
Michael Cyril Creighton
Mabel and Talbert kissed by the suspect
board which makes perfect sense because
every love interest in this show has
been a murderer or a suspect Jan Alice
Oscar Loretta Joy Talbert
is this a coincidence can they ever be
in a normal relationship is the trio in
love with murder
let's see what our guests think welcome
Sophia coppo Jason VC and Jay Manuel hey
how are you all we're great fabulous
good I'm glad to hear it I feel
underdressed
all right so let's start
are our wonderful Trio in love with
murder I would have to say there's
definitely a toxic pattern going on here
absolutely
as it is yeah yes we all have it theirs
happens to be a murder yeah is there a
world though where yes they are
passionate about solving a crime but
women maybe they're more in love with is
the bonding time that it has for all of
them do you mean that there's a short
amount of time like because these people
are going to go to jail it's like it's
like in the olden times when you'd marry
someone before they went off to war yeah
don't want to break up with them falling
in love with people before they're found
of murder they do their work and they're
sleeping with the murderers exactly yeah
that's exactly it you know what I feel
like it's murder is somewhat of an
aphrodisiac when it comes to these three
am I over analyzing it a little bit and
they all walk around with their own set
of blinders on but in different ways
like if we look at Mabel I mean first of
all last season we learned that she has
the ability to block things out and she
came up with this whole idea of
dissociation around her father's death
and I mean rightly so that was
traumatizing she was a young girl but
like now she with Alice you know she was
a very realistic suspect in Bunny's
murder but she was kind of into that
relationship and then she was flirting
with Theo at Coney Island you know it's
just like all these things like so I
feel like she has a way of blocking out
like these are murderers or potential
murderers and yet I think I mean I don't
know maybe I'm getting like way too it
makes perfect sense like do we all
forget that Theo is
but can we talk about tobbert for just a
moment he's sketchy
see see a little sketchy he tricked her
I'm telling y'all those eyes are going
to have you hiding a body I don't trust
him you will compromise yourself in your
morals with that face stay away from me
he could get away with murder stay away
which makes sense that Mabel is being
drawn to him oh yeah they met both going
to break into the penthouse yeah at that
murder board that that was sensual I
would say it was such with the string
and the kissing and it was even when
they were locked in the the armoire
together
it was just they're they're
investigating something together yes are
they forgetting each other
so Charles stated Jan yes murderer yeah
what I always think of when I see
Charles visiting Jan in prison and he's
like slowly getting like roped back into
her he's getting aroused for sure
something's happening there about
everything it's like when you don't tell
your best friend like you're not taking
her advice and he goes back to the crew
and he's like lying about being with Jan
even he was falling for a murderer fully
knowing because she's in prison what she
did right also she tried to kill him so
that is a real toxic trait yeah
exactly and then he dated and proposed
to Joy and then accused her of murder
right yeah and then sabotage that whole
relationship the engagement's off
and do you think he sabotaged the
relationship because he realized she
wasn't a murderer oh see I I actually
think that's the case yeah because he
actually he actually said earlier on you
know he's not really good with people in
his space in his house right so when she
comes in with the fish first of all when
she came in with the fish she'd have to
go yeah yeah okay already it was a lot
and they have pretty great chemistry
they do yeah they do uh what's it called
the aardvark no the uh yeah was it the
aardvark with like a chimpanzee sound
effect the antelope the antelope that
sounded like a primary they have great
chemistry and she's so supportive of
Charles and has been there from the
beginning and the fact that he was able
to decide that she was a murderer yes
might have been a way for him to try to
decide that he loved her I love that you
say that she's been supportive from the
beginning when the first thing she said
first time you sat in my chair 30 years
ago I thought you were gonna die alone
yes
now
wonderful sweet Oliver is now drawn to
Loretta only to find out that she is
also a suspect
could you imagine finding that book
after sleeping with someone
I think Oliver likes the theatricality
in the drama of the situation so I think
it's kind of like oh wow this is crazy
but like what a story I can use this
somewhere yeah you know maybe I have a
completely different take on this
because I feel like she might just be an
Uber fan I feel like it's just too
obvious that she really could be a
suspect yeah I do agree I don't know I'm
not ruling anybody out including you
okay including me you guys probably
didn't do it because you're not on the
show
I think we might live in the building
though that's true it's a huge building
um do we think that the trio are capable
of having a normal relationship or is
this pattern just going to continue and
continue and continue I think they in
order to do that they might have to move
to a building where people don't die
every year right in order to sort of
move forward have a nice sweet
relationship just go to a regular
building where people stay alive yeah
while we're here because you don't talk
to I have a question for you though yeah
okay so you live in New York yes so now
let's just say there was a murder in
your building would you move out no when
I I would not but here's the thing if if
every year someone one of my neighbors
keeps dropping like flies it's time for
me yeah or fell down An Elevator Shaft
oh yeah I'm bouncing Sophia Jason Jay
thank you so much for being here it's
been so fun talking to you and having
you on that couch
and on that note it's time to play
one killer game
where I play the tooth fairy
here I am dressed in this outfit that
I'm so happy to be in
I am the tooth fairy
okay guys we're going to guess what
Oliver wished for with that tooth
and I'm going to listen
okay so I'm going to maintain that
Oliver is all about work so it's work
work work first because remember when he
was hugging will in that tender moment
talking about Teddy being his real dad
then the phone call yes and he's like
maybe I shouldn't look maybe I should
look oh it's a producer you know what
let me take it right work first so even
though he's with Loretta and it's this
whole romantic moment
I think he's thinking about work so he
wished for
a Tony Award
for his first big musical Splash
absolutely
similar I'm going to expand I think that
he truly wishes that the love of his
life becomes a star
and it's the love of his life himself
or Loretta I think it's Loretta you're
right it's Loretta I think it's best of
both worlds yeah hope she's not a
murderer let me
I was going to say I think his wish is
that Loretta is not a murderer oh
yeah that's true I don't know yeah yeah
that's a good one maybe I think the
three of you perfectly crafted what
Oliver would wish for and I have decided
that granted granted I want Oliver to be
happy I want everybody in this show to
be happy well this was real fun and such
a dream thank you all for being here
and until next time thanks for watching
one killer question may all your wishes
come true
taking this off
[Music]